[Applause]
matthew stafford wasn't the only
longtime veteran to win his first super
bowl my guy rams offensive lineman
andrew whitworth big wit got his ring
after 16 years in the nfl
at 40 years old he is the oldest active
player in the league and still doing it
at a high level and he joins us right
now big whit how are you doing
congratulations man
i tell you what man it's awfully special
a lot of people a lot a lot of people to
thank it's uh you know how it is it's
the whole organization there's so many
people that go into this
just an unbelievable feeling
big wig i gotta ask how did you
celebrate i mean have you even went to
sleep yet
i have not we went to a little after
event with all the all the family and
friends and uh you know i spent some
time with matthew and cooper and
just some of the guys just uh
fellowshipping and reminiscing and man
it's it's awfully special i'll tell you
what it makes it a lot of fun when
there's so many guys that you want to
win it for and to see all those guys
enjoying it just makes it extra special
you mentioned family we're looking at
images of you with your kids how does it
feel to share that moment with those
that are so close to you
i'll tell you what it's really special
mate i mean you know i look back to 2018
when we lost the super bowl i had a
moment where my wife was holding one of
my my middle son michael
and he's bawling crying and i flexed up
my muscles up at him and told him to
stop crying because we don't cry we just
handle situations and move on
and then tonight to win it i remember
looking up at him in the stands and
flexing the same way at him
and telling him now you can have tears
of joy
big wit if it wasn't for the salt and
pepper in your beard i couldn't tell how
old you are i mean you're dominant on
the field and you still look good but at
40 years old i have to ask what's next
are you retiring you're coming back to
football
i don't know yet you know i mean it's
one of those things that we'll sit back
after the season ends now and in these
next couple weeks those decisions will
be made and you know i'll reflect on
what's uh what's important for me and
the family
and obviously sit down sit down with
sean mcvay and just talk about you know
what we think the next chapter is we'll
sit back and kind of see what's next for
both of us and and see where it goes
from there
walter payton man of the year and now
super bowl champion nobody more
deserving than you my brother
congratulations thank you for joining us
thank you so much i appreciate it